il ya des choses que moi je préfère
grâce à cette main mais y'a personne
d'autre ce qui peut faire comme par
exemple tourner le poignet
si je veux prendre une prise comme ça
c'est mieux que si je le ressens un
christ comme ça je met le couteau comme
ça pour que je puisse avoir un appui
pour manger comme ça pour pousser les
aliments vers ma fourchette
[Musique]
chaque début d'année donc je suis tout
petit je montre en heures de vie de
classe tout de suite ma prothèse comme
ça c'est fait c'est 10 h des fois ça
fait le bruit mécanique de sa main kim
âgée c'est assez perturbant parce que
avant on entendait on entend des reins
du coup mais à force on s y habitue
du coup ça fait dans la classe
généralement le bruit c'est le maître en
marrant il lui dit chute à sa prothèse
oui c'est faire rigoler de la classe
avec sa prothèse dans des projets maman
qu'on va faire de bruit jamais ça va
c'est un instrument de vie c'est comme
un vêtement donc je ne m'en prive pas je
perçois ça plutôt comme une force car un
handicap
j'ai des copains de classe qui la
première fois ils ont vu la prothèse et
ils ont été bluffés quand même j'en ai
même un qui m'a dit tout ça s'achète
donc ils ont été impressionnés par la
prothèse en elle même et je suis sûr
qu'on peut faire des grandes choses même
si on a un handicap pour ce qui est de
ma prothèse d'avant ma prothèse vous
avez un effet de pain c'est à dire à ne
pouvait que faire ça donc les mouvements
n'étaient pas faits a été limitée savez
couleur peau j'ai plus simple chez bahl
a par exemple prendre les pièces indique
avance fallait bien un prix il faut y
est bien précis et cetera
[Musique]
rodrigues as-tu du col c'est archi
maintenant beurre omnia
[Musique]
en fait quand je fais ça ça sauf quand
je fais ça ça se ferme
c'est capté grâce à des capteurs il ya
ces capteurs n'a d'ailleurs ça va je
vais y arriver mais un moment ça va
glisser est jamais très ça jamais à ces
pressions en fait par exemple le sac
c'est beaucoup trop lourd pour que je
puisse porter si j'essaie je suis sûr
qu'il ya des éléments comme le pouce qui
vont casser par exemple donc j'aimerais
une prothèse pareil c'est parfait mais
avec un petit peu plus de pression quand
même ça serait ça mon rêve